il y a un être humain vraiment compliqué
en dessous qui cherche son identité
et en essayant de trouver sa voie dans le
monde
[Musique] il
y a une magie en lui qui n'existe
qu'avec quelques personnes
[Musique]
Je pourrais m'identifier à un Américain de première génération
et  c'est un immigré immigrant
nommé Farouk al-shara,
c'est très difficile, je pense, de venir dans
un pays tout nouveau à cet
âge et de commencer à assimiler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est beau chez lui, c'est qu'il a trouvé un
moyen de s'accepter  et il y a une
liberté qui vient avec et je pense
que la liberté s'accentue quand il est
sur scène
[Musique]
le notionnel donc un livre avec du sexe mes
connaissances personnelles et la passion comme
costumes tout le Montaigne je n'y vais pas
pour plus d'inspiration je  je vois juste un
travail commun, juste nerveux, c'est comme un
9h à 17h
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le charisme et la relation qu'il entretient
avec le public ne ressemblent à rien de ce que
j'ai jamais vu auparavant
[Musique]
[  Musique]
Les plats de la deuxième vallée de Mugen au Japon
n'ont pas été assez confidentiels
[Musique]
si je suis encore en vie, je reviendrai